- I am not surprised to
see the end of Trump's,
at least first four
years ending chaotically
since that is how they began,
and that is how they went.
And that is why he was
elected in the first place,
to be a disruptor.
So why are people so shocked
that he continues to disrupt?
(bright music)
- All right, this is "The
Rubin Report," I'm Dave Rubin.
and we are doing a quick
on-the-fly interview today
because I mentioned on
the show the other day,
I don't know who
to trust anymore.
I don't know who's making sense.
I don't know who's looking
at the world with clear eyes
and I went through
my mental rolodex
and Megyn Kelly popped up.
And Megyn, you agreed to
do the show just like that.
And here we are. How you doing?
- I'm doing well. For
you, Dave, anytime.
Clear eyes, full
heart, can't lose.
- All right, well, here are my
notes for today's interview.
- Oh, (laughing) You're
just like Amy Coney Barrett.
- I got nothing.
Although my guys did tell me,
this is gonna air on Sunday.
We're taping this
Friday afternoon.
So people will
have to bear with,
if any little crazy vote got
changed or anything else.
But generally speaking, as we
tape this on Friday afternoon,
how are you feeling about
the state of this election?
The media portion of it,
the recount portion of it,
Biden, Trump, the
whole damn thing.
- I have a lot of thoughts,
a lot of thoughts.
- (laughing) Let's do
'em, one at a time.
- I am not surprised to
see the end of Trump's,
at least first four
years ending chaotically
since that is how they began,
and that is how they went.
And that is why he was
elected in the first place
to be a disruptor.
So why are people so shocked
that he continues to disrupt
right up to the last,
what appear to be the
last final moments of,
if not his presidency,
the time in his presidency
before election?
I think Trump has lost. I do.
I know people don't
want to hear that,
but I think he's lost.
And I think a lot of people
are struggling to
accept it, right?
It's like a grief process.
The first step is denial.
We should do all the stuff.
We should check out what's
happening in Pennsylvania.
He should see those
legal challenges through.
We should make sure we
have a Wisconsin recount,
and a Georgia recount.
But my assessment from
where I sit out here
is there are not
enough gettable votes
even if he can prove fraud
or some untoward process
with the mail-in votes, to
get him over the top anymore,
that phase has passed.
- Do you have faith
that the numbers
that we're getting are real?
Do you have faith that not
only the people on the ground,
in whatever state
you want to pick,
whatever city you want to
pick, are being honest,
and that is being
translated to us
honestly through the media,
do you have faith in that?
- Not utter faith,
but enough faith.
These are the same people who
did the count four years ago
and he won, so let's be real.
They didn't just
become fraudulent,
vote counters in
the past four years.
And they also hated
him four years ago.
It's not like they loved him.
They thought he was going to
be full of love and rainbows
when he got into office.
They wanted to kill
him four years ago.
And you know, Philadelphia's
famous for its voter fraud.
And so these problems have
existed long before now.
And what I'm seeing in the
electoral process is, to me,
it's akin to when we
went HD in television,
where everything
looked just fine
when it was a little fuzzy.
And then, when you could see
it up close and personal,
it was like, my eyes!
Oh, my God! I didn't want
to see this, it's hideous.
And that's what's happening
with our electoral process.
It isn't perfect,
it's far from perfect.
It's the best we have.
Should we do better?
Can we do better? Yes.
And yes. Hello Florida.
Let's just be like Florida,
but we're not right now.
And we're not going to
get it to the point of,
ah, now it's perfect.
And we can perfectly know that
every vote that was proper
was counted and every
one that wasn't, was not.
It's not going to
happen, people.
That's not the way
our system is built.
So we're gonna have
to do good enough.
That's how the system's set up.
Even the votes he's counting,
even the ones he was like,
that was fraudulently filled
out, or that's ba ba ba,
you're talking about handfuls,
handfuls here and there.
You're not talking
about 70,000 votes
that's gonna get him
over the top in Arizona,
that's not going to happen.
The places where it's
tightest, Biden is ahead.
Biden is ahead right
now in Georgia.
Biden is ahead in a
couple of these states
that Trump is contesting.
So I just think the odds of
Trump turning this around
right now are infantesimal.
And so I'm not saying
it's totally impossible,
but realistically, if you
want to know what I think,
I think he's lost and I don't
think his legal challenges
or the recounts are
gonna amount to much.
- Yeah. So, what do
you think he'll do?
Do you think he
just runs the table
with every legal
course of action
and just does
absolutely anything?
Or do you sense that
maybe at some point,
if what you're saying is right,
that he will throw in the towel?
- I know the throwing in the
towel doesn't sound like Trump.
And I also think he owes
it to his supporters
who love him and don't trust
these systems for good reasons
to see these challenges through.
I have no problem with
him stoking those fires
and getting in there and making
sure, to the extent he can,
maybe it's his final
act as president
right before his lame
duck period to disrupt
yet another system to
upend it, blow it up,
and ultimately make
it better, right?
Tear it down so we
can come back better
for the next four year period.
But I support his
willingness to challenge,
where he has good faith
evidence of a problem,
like what happened
in Pennsylvania
with allowing the mail-in votes
to be postmarked
on election day,
something that was approved
by judges and not legislators,
which is not okay.
The court refused to
take that challenge.
They said, get back to us
if this becomes an ongoing
problem after the election.
And if there's a
split in the states
that we might have to resolve.
He should pursue
that, he should.
But again, it doesn't look
like there are enough votes
in that pile that
could help him.
Anyway, I think he
should see it through,
I don't think he should
give up before he has to,
but I think realistically,
when it becomes
clear that he's lost,
we're gonna need the people
who are closest to him,
who he trusts, not the
media, which he doesn't,
for good reason, to
sit him down and say,
it's no longer about you,
this is about the country.
And there will be a
peaceful transfer of power.
And while you can go
out there and say,
I have real problems
with the way
the system conducted itself.
And I don't know
about this vote.
I am going to pass the
torch and put America first
to quote somebody we all know.
- Do you think that part
of his calculation of,
even if he sees
it, that he's lost,
like the challenges
aren't going anywhere?
That part of it will be
the burn it down thing,
because even just a few
minutes before we started here,
I saw a tweet by
AOC and, in effect,
we're going to have
to come for Trump,
they keep saying enablers and
the sycophants and whatever.
And it's like, a few
weeks ago, Robert Reich,
who was in the
Clinton administration
talked about a truth and
reconciliation commission
and that these people love lists
and all of these weird things.
And it's like, for all
the chants of lock her up,
it never happened.
There was nobody knocking
on Hillary's door
that Trump may feel,
and I think actually for good
reason that these people,
whether the guy did
anything illegal or not,
they've created this monster
in their heads, let's say,
and that they will do
things that are unimaginable
in the American
political landscape.
- I think, yes, they will.
It's not paranoia when they
really are out to get you.
And that explains a lot
of Trump's behavior.
I think the media
is so disgusted
by his rhetoric from
the White House.
And they're like, it's not
great. I'm not gonna defend it.
but I understand where
he's coming from.
They have been out to get
him for more than four years.
The media is his enemy. They
absolutely are his enemy.
And the Democrats loathe
him in a special way.
One does have to wonder if a
lot of these Democrats think
the ends justify the means.
We really have had a baseless
attempt to impeach the guy
that was right on the heels
of a completely made up
Russia investigation,
and not to mention all
the non controversies
the media fed off of
for the last four years.
So he is right to
totally distrust them.
The pollsters have
had it totally wrong
when it comes to
Trump all along.
I do want to make a distinction
between the pollsters
who predict vote
prior to the vote
and the people at
the decision desks
who analyze for a
living raw vote tallies,
two totally different animals.
So just because we don't
trust the pollsters
like Nate Silver doesn't
mean we shouldn't trust
the Fox News Decision
Desk, but anyway,
Trump has a general
distrust of these systems,
that's well-founded.
And so do his fans.
And that's why I think people
aren't being nuts right now.
It's not crazy conspiratorial,
but it's based on data
it's based on experience.
And to expect the left
to understand any of that
is too much to expect.
They won't. There isn't
grace on the other side.
I mean, there's great guys
like Andrew Yang, right?
Who's saying all the right
things, like be cool.
And let's not go too
far and whatever.
And then there's just jerks
like AOC or Nancy Pelosi
coming out and saying,
we have a mandate,
which you don't even
have close to a mandate.
and one other point on her,
the more you say
you have a mandate,
which you clearly do
not, you lost House seats
instead of gaining
them, it looks like
you're not gonna have
control of the Senate,
you didn't get the Blue Wave
at the presidential level,
the more the Republicans, if
they do take over that Senate
are gonna do to stymie every
piece of Joe Biden's agenda.
There will be no grace
on their side either.
- I actually read your
tweet about Nancy Pelosi
and the mandate on
my show this morning.
And I was trying to frame it
in a way that will give people,
obviously a lot of my
audience likes Trump,
so I was trying to say,
okay, if this doesn't work,
if this doesn't end up the
way you want it to end up,
what are the silver
linings around this thing?
And I agree with you that
her tweet or her comment
was so over the top
that maybe it gets the
Republicans to dig.
And then I'm starting to think,
I'm not a statist, generally
in a traditional sense,
but I'm starting
to think that maybe
instead of the small
government that I really want,
maybe we never
really get to that.
But maybe the best
thing we could have
is sort of like an endlessly
stalemated government
that basically just
can't do anything.
And then what'll happen
is every four years
we'll have the guy
do executive actions
and then the next guy
will reverse them.
And that'll just be
the way we're governed.
And I know it kind of sucks.
And for those of us that
do this for a living,
it's not really what you want,
but maybe in a bizarre sense,
that's the last fail
safe that we have,
does that make any sense?
- Stasis, stasis
could be okay, right?
I think that the Democrats
would much have preferred stasis
to Trump doing
anything meaningful.
And I think that's how the
Republicans are feeling now.
My own sense of it
is most Republicans
aren't that scared of
Joe Biden, the man,
because he has a 50 year history
of legislating from the middle,
but Joe Biden is elderly
and not totally with it
mentally from what we've seen.
And I think a lot of
people are worried
that he is just
gonna be the puppet
and people like AOC
and Nancy Pelosi
are gonna be the puppeteers.
And I realize those two women
don't have the same agenda.
But as far as Republicans are
concerned, neither is good.
You're not gonna
have some moderate,
Joe Manchin pulling the
strings on Joe Biden.
It's gonna be people
like that, the squad,
and nobody wants the
squad getting in there
and telling him what to do,
or just pressuring him
so much that he does it.
So I think statis would be okay,
but I think it could
be worse than stasis.
It could be a bloody
civil war, if you will,
or political civil war,
forgive the reference.
Because if they
do go after Trump,
if they decide to go after him
legally and put him in jail
and undo everything,
completely go after Trump
and his supporters,
the Senate does a lot.
If Republicans
control the Senate,
I know we're looking at
two runoffs in Georgia,
Republicans have
never lost a runoff
in the state of Georgia, never.
Now realize we're gonna
have a huge money dump there
to try to change that
this time around.
And Georgia's changing. It's
becoming bluer obviously.
But the odds are
on the GOP's side.
So let's assume for now,
the GOP retains
control of the Senate.
If they retain
control of the Senate
and the Democrats
do all those things,
they're gonna make it as
ugly and as acrimonious
and as unfortunate for
the Dems as possible.
A lot of these cabinet choices
have to be confirmed
by the Senate, right?
What if a justice,
God forbid dies
and you need confirmation
by the Senate?
There's a lot the Senate can do
to stop a president from
getting anything done.
And then in two years
we have another election
and the Democrats share
of the House majority,
it's going down like
this as we speak,
it's getting smaller and
smaller, and smaller.
And it could get down
when all is said and done,
to just a four seat
advantage by the Dems.
If that happens,
they're almost certainly
gonna lose control in two years.
So politics never stops.
If you are just a complete
prick two and four years later,
it's gonna come back at you.
- Right.
And then when you look at some
of the interesting numbers
that broke in different
ways that Black men
voted more than two times
as high for a Republican
as they did last
time, and Black women,
it went up from 4% to 8%.
That's not a huge percentage,
but doubling is pretty good.
I saw something this
morning that 16%,
I think, of Muslims
voted for Trump.
All things that you
just wouldn't expect,
that LGBT support for Trump
actually more than doubled.
So there are some
interesting signs of future.
How worried are you
just about general trust
in the whole damn thing,
like that the same people
who said Russia, are
now saying our election
is tamper-proof, right?
That's the big one
that I'm seeing,
the hypocrisy on right now,
you guys ran around saying
Russia interfered in our
elections four years ago.
Now you're telling us because
you got what you wanted,
apparently that the
system is perfect.
So that people won't trust
the electoral system.
They already don't
trust the media system.
That basically, all
of our, the colleges,
just the institutional level,
there is just no trust
in anything anymore.
And I can't really fake
it for people. You know?
I wish these things were better,
but I don't think they are.
- Well, some of that concerns
me, but most of it doesn't.
For example, I think Joe,
Biden's not gonna pack
the Supreme Court
and that's good
because that would have
been a massive move
that would have ruined
the Supreme Court.
And that would have been the
end of the Supreme Court.
And that would've
been a catastrophic
breakdown of systems.
- What if it ain't Joe?
'Cause I'm with you on that?
I think Joe actually-
- No, there's not support for
it within the Democratic party
or writ large, there isn't.
- You think by him getting
in, it's fed them enough
that they won't have
to do the crazy stuff.
- I even think if Kamala Harris
were at the top of
the ticket right now
and ascending to the White
House, it wouldn't happen.
There isn't support for
it in the United States.
The people don't want it.
You know that FDR
couldn't get it through
when he controlled his party,
Democrats controlled
the House and the Senate
and he was hugely popular.
Well, the support
right now is 20% lower
for packing the court
than it was back then.
It's not gonna happen.
People don't want it.
These politicians aren't
politically suicidal.
So that was a good talking
point by Jeffrey Toobin
who really should've
been more focused
on how to work his Zoom than
writing provocative articles
in the New Yorker about shit
that's never gonna happen.
I don't think Joe
Biden's gonna do that.
I think the reason he
wouldn't answer that
when he was running is
because the answer was no,
it was to protect his left
flank, him from his left flank,
not to protect himself
from the right.
But I also kind of
think that distrust
in some agencies can be good
and it's not all destructive.
I think the media
needed to be destroyed.
And now it will rebuild in
some way, shape or form.
I really think, I've
said this to you before
that the journalists,
they'd been on a kamikaze
mission ever since Trump.
It didn't start with Trump,
but, that was the real mission.
They've been on a
kamikaze mission
to take him down and it
wound up being a thing
where they did kill themselves.
And in the end, it does appear
they took him with them.
It does appear, they
brought him down
because if you don't think
the media played a role
in people's perceptions of
Trump these past four years,
as controversial as he
is legitimately bad,
I don't mean to
give him a full pass
on all the crazy
stuff he's done.
But the media did so much of it.
They are a force, I don't
want to say for evil,
that's too strong, but
they're not to be trusted.
And they're not what
they used to be.
And they're not honest about it.
So they needed to be destroyed
and we'll see what comes up.
So maybe that's true in the
FBI, they needed to be unmasked
as this political organization.
I had complete trust in
James Comey, David, I did
I was like, Jim Comey!
The guy, wrong.
- Yeah.
- And I'm grateful for having
that that mask pulled off.
I can't totally dismiss
the dismantling of trust
in some of these organizations.
- Well, that's what I'm saying.
I'm down with the
distrust stuff.
I don't think they
deserve our trust anymore.
But the problem is that it
sort of only got halfway.
In other words, if Trump loses,
well, then they've
been unmasked,
but they're about to rebuild.
You can already feel
it a little bit.
Like, oh, they
didn't fully get us,
so here we go, again,
something like that.
- No, no, no, I don't
think that's right.
Because they never lost
trust with the Democrats.
They've had it.
We're just going to a more
fractured media world.
Like the country used to
have when we were founded
and for the 100
years thereafter,
where, the left has its sources
and the right has its sources.
But one great thing Trump
did was make very clear
that virtually everybody
is on that first side.
Virtually everybody is actually
fighting for Democrats.
There's not a Republican in
the country left, I think,
that thinks CNN is fair
and objective news.
Maybe some people who
really don't pay attention
to the news might
still think that.
But Republicans
haven't been fooled,
the mask has been pulled off.
So that's a good thing.
I think they're gonna be
very defensive of Joe Biden.
I think quietly,
the Washington Post,
Democracy Dies in Darkness
is going to just get
pulled off the masthead
and put over there.
(laughing)
It's no longer dark,
so we don't need-
to do that anymore.
- Yeah.
- But I think all
of that's great,
and it gives the audience,
let me put it to you this way,
if you have a friend
who's a real jerk
and you didn't know it,
I'm thinking of my
one friend's example.
I'll give you this, friends
of ours, interracial couple,
the husband's black,
the wife is white.
And after the
George Floyd thing,
they were very upset because
one of their white friends
called them up and said,
"How are you doing?
I hope you're okay."
And then they found out,
oh, no, you know what?
I can't tell the whole story
'cause that would
reveal who it was.
But it was somebody who
they thought was a friend
and who they had helped out
with respect to their
kid, getting into college.
They had done a lot to help him.
And basically the guy got outed
as repeatedly saying the N word
and really racist stuff
about black people.
So they were shocked.
They were horrified.
And I said to them, you know
what, this is a good thing.
Because that was the
reality yesterday.
And you just didn't know.
It's better today to know,
and then act accordingly.
It's hurtful to find out,
but it's not better
to be in the dark.
And that's how I
feel about the media
and these organizations,
which really are politically
driven, but we didn't know it.
May hurt to learn it or
not, but it's better to know
and then act accordingly.
- Yeah. I'm with you on that.
Well, what do you think about
the big tech element then,
also that going
forward that at least,
even though they did
nothing, I kept saying this
the whole time you guys
are having these hearings
and it's great to see Ted Cruz
who I totally like and respect.
It's great to see
him grill Jack,
but you guys are doing it
six days before an election.
And we're pretending
that this isn't theater.
Are you worried that, okay,
Trump was the last thing
that was stopping
big tech from doing
whatever it might want to do.
I don't know exactly
what it wants to do.
But now without that threat
of, we're gonna regulate you,
whatever it might, break you up,
stuff that I don't
particularly want them to do.
Are you worried that they're
just going to go all in
and silence the real resistance,
which will be, the
remaining free thinkers?
- Yes, I am worried about that.
I don't have the
solution to that either.
I am worried.
I think one of the sad things,
the realities is over
the past 20, 25 years,
is the Republicans
have shown themselves
to be very good at
winning elections.
Maybe not in this particular
case for the White House,
but in general,
they win elections
and very bad at fighting
the culture wars.
And it's unfortunate
because now the Democrats
control the media, Hollywood,
academia, big tech,
and half the country
doesn't feel represented at all
in almost all of the information
that comes back
to them publicly,
like sports, forgot
to mention them.
So you turn on the television
to watch a sports game
or get the news, or
watch the "Oscars"
or the "VMAs," whatever it is.
And now you're getting
wokeism shoved down your neck,
and you're being
told you're a racist
if you happen to be a
Republican, you like Trump,
or even just if you're
a Republican these days.
And you send out a tweet
that is totally legitimate
and maybe just opinionated
or a news story
being reported by
that New York Post,
censored, censored, censored.
Your viewpoints,
you're being told
they're bad by everyone
that has control of
the public microphones.
And I do think it leads people
to be like, am I insane?
Is everything I think
awful? It's a problem.
Now. I think big tech
is part of the problem.
I really wish we'd see
somebody like Peter Thiel,
who, you know,
he's gonna have to actively
create a new Twitter
and a new Facebook.
There needs to be a real,
other digital forum out there
that represents the other
half of the country.
'Cause I just don't think
they've got much of a future
on the existing platforms.
- Well, the irony
is if Trump loses
and then it finally gives him
the impetus to be like, okay,
I'm going to another platform
or I'm starting my own platform.
That's how the platform
will work. Right?
That ultimately would be it.
- I don't think so.
- No? You don't think
that would be enough?
- No, with all due respect,
Sean Hannity starting
his own network.
You know what you're gonna get.
You're not gonna
get real analysis.
- I don't mean
you'll get analysis.
I mean, if Trump is
just like, all right,
I'm going to Parler
or I'm going to locals
or wherever that it would be
like everyone would go there
just because he's still
the show in a way.
- No question.
- I don't mean
that he's going to create
some non-partisan network.
- Conservative media
is well-represented
in the digital world.
I get that.
But when it comes to the
main platforms out there,
Facebook is, it gives
a little bit more play.
But they're censoring
a lot of stuff too.
But if you could have a real,
and I know there's Parler,
I'm on Parler, but it's just,
it's not what Twitter is.
And I don't know that
it's going to be,
you need a real player
with a lot of money
to create the
platform and back it.
And somebody with
a spine of steel,
like Rupert Murdoch to say,
I don't need to be loved
at the cocktail parties.
I'm gonna let this
be a real forum
for mainstream
conservative thought.
In other words, we don't need
Alex Jones on there. Okay.
But like Dave Rubin does not
need to get censored. Right?
And that's my only
thought because,
you're not gonna
change Jack Dorsey.
You're not gonna
change Facebook.
You're not gonna change
these big tech organizations
for whom it's
deeply ideological.
They think it's the difference
between good and evil.
It's not just about
getting Biden elected.
It's about silencing the
rest of these racists!
Did you see that clip from
Sunny Hostin on "The View?"
- Yeah. Unbelievable.
- That embodies how they
think, the left wing.
And I don't even
mean progressives.
I know you used to be one.
Most progressives I
know are totally normal
and mainstream and
they don't believe
in any of this nonsense.
It's the quote Left with a
capital L who are insane,
in the way they see the
other half of the country.
And Sunny Hostin just
put it on display
where it was like, at
least half the country.
I'm not gonna say they're
racists, but they're racist.
(laughing) I didn't
say they're racist,
but at least half the
country voted for him
notwithstanding his
racism, his sexism,
his xenophobia, his transphobia.
And then another woman
on the panel, Sarah,
I don't remember her
name, but she was like,
how can you say that?
People vote in their own
self-interest all the time,
pocket book issues, and so
on, it doesn't make them bad.
It doesn't make them racist.
And the response was no,
because this is
about we the people
and we are supposed to
behave as a collective
and do what is right.
One of those things, Dave,
I was like, oh my God,
I wish so badly, for the
first time in my life
that I were sitting
on "The View."
(laughing)
I would have loved to said
to her, I get it. Totally.
And just out of
curiosity, I'm wondering,
'cause there's a lotta
people who really feel like,
for example, abortion is murder
and it's actually killing
babies and that's wrong.
And what would be right
would be to ban it outright.
And if you don't support that,
you are on the wrong side,
you're in favor of murder.
And we the people respond to you
to behave as a
collective, right?
I could go on, give
five other examples-
And by the way, let's look
at the Southern border.
You know, the people down there
who have had family
members killed by people
illegally coming across
with drugs and weapons,
who have lost jobs to people
who are here unlawfully
in the country.
They have real reasons for
wanting a great border wall
and for cracking down
on illegal immigration.
And if you don't support it,
you're the one who doesn't care
about life and the wellbeing
of your fellow citizens
and we the people.
Who died and made her king
of we the people, right?
That's how they think, the left.
- Do you think they'll
ever stop that thing?
That, in many ways, what
you just described there,
that is the thing
that the rest of us
are fighting, we don't have
to make it about Sunny.
But that thing, and
it's been so successful.
And as we're talking,
potentially is about to
dethrone Donald Trump,
why would they stop doing it?
- They're not going to,
they're not going to.
I agreed with the
headlines this week
that said wokeism was dealt
a blow during this election
because you saw his
numbers, as you pointed out,
with all these
minority groups go up.
The minority groups like
him more than they used to,
not less like four years of
ubiquitous media coverage
telling them he's awful
racist, bigot, all this stuff.
And that they're
awful if they like it.
So that didn't work.
Oh, and by the way,
even just today,
there was a Democratic
congresswoman who was saying
defund the police
killed us, killed us.
That is why we went down
in the House instead of up.
And if we don't abandon
that ridiculous messaging,
we're going to see a
blood bath in two years.
Wokeism, the messaging
was proven to be a failure
when it comes to
electoral politics,
but that won't deter them.
That's not going
to stop anything,
for the reasons I was saying.
It's ideological.
It makes them feel like
better people, superior,
I don't know if
it's their guilt.
If it's just the
virtue signaling
makes them feel great about
themselves in bed at night
when they judge other people
and decide they're all bad.
So we're gonna have
to deal with it.
And the people who don't
believe in this BS culture,
and there's so many
people in the center right
who don't either.
Look at the Harper's letter.
Look at people like Andrew
Sullivan who hated Trump,
but he's completely taken a
stand against this baloney.
They're gonna have to speak up.
The people who are against
it, I know they're afraid.
I know you can get fired now
for the most ridiculous
reasons, trust me I know.
We're gonna have to
start taking risks.
Otherwise we're all
going to go down.
We're going to go down
together on this war.
- Yeah, on a personal note,
as you were watching
the election
and you're not in the big
studio and doing all that stuff,
that you've done in the past,
did you enjoy it
more in a weird way?
'Cause you could
just kind of watch it
and be on your couch or
were you on your couch?
Where were you?
- I was, yeah.
I was doing a bunch of hits
from here, my living room.
- Oh right, you
were on "Daily Wire"
right before me that
night, you were home.
- Yeah I saw you.
Can I tell you honestly,
that's the first time
that I've actually
missed being on TV
since I went off TV, I love
those big election nights.
I think I know how
to anchor them well.
It's one of those things where
if you're a strong pitcher
and you see somebody else
pitching in the big game,
you're like, hmm, I wish
I could be doing it.
So that was one of
the first nights
I think that I actually thought,
oh, I'd love to be out there,
but that's not to not
to disparage anybody
who was out there.
Just that I sort of missed
throwing my fast ball.
- Yeah.
So what's next then for the
Megyn Kelly media empire,
if you miss that?
- No, no, no.
- I sense something.
You just said you
missed something.
- Not at all. No, no, no,
no. I love what I'm doing.
I am loving my podcast.
It's like, I'm home.
I chose right.
This is exactly right.
For me, it's a new forum.
It's one in which I can use
all aspects of my personality.
I'm loving it,
but that doesn't mean it
can scratch every itch.
But I have no desire to go back
to Fox or cable news at all.
As you know, I left it
for very good reasons.
That would be 11,
9 and 7 right now.
And they're more important to
me than taking care of that.
- I don't think that
I asked you this
when I had you on
a couple weeks ago,
but what is your philosophical
or religious?
What is the thing
that's beneath politics
that keeps you sane
throughout this?
Because when we're
talking about the people
that use this in a religious
nature and how wokeism
has caused so much destruction
and caused people to become
believers who otherwise,
usually aren't believers
in a traditional sense.
I find the only people
that are making sense to me
these days are people
that come at it
from some sort of belief aspect.
They can have very
various versions of it,
but what is like beneath your
political outlook of life?
- It's more like it's above
my political outlook of life.
I just feel like politics
is over here and I'm here.
This is something we talk about,
it's not who I am, it's not
really that important to me.
I have to get involved
'cause it brings up
important fights.
That one must fight
and I cover it,
as a journalist
and a commentator.
I am a woman of faith,
I'm not particularly
observant in my Catholicism,
but I was raised Catholic
and I have that
moral imprint on me.
And I believe in God
and I totally believe
in an afterlife
and a higher power.
I guess I just believe
what we're here for
is our human connections
and not any of this BS.
This is small stuff
that people use
who enjoy divisiveness,
they enjoy hostility.
And I really believe
a lot of them
have too little fulfillment
in their own lives.
The smaller your life gets,
the more you feel the need
to fill it with something
else, be it drama,
be it anger, fighting,
I'm not in that boat.
I am filling the main pitcher
over here, P-I-T-C-H-E-R,
my children, my husband, my
marriage, my friendships,
myself, my enjoyment in life.
And then politics is over here.
And I take a swim over
and I'll fight where
I need to fight.
But I just think people who
have nothing to remind them,
it's just a limited time
we're here together.
Make bad choices.
And I'll put one period on it.
I interviewed Adam
Corolla recently
who I just adore.
- Yeah, me too.
- And he said it
in such a good way.
He said, I have no time for
people who obsess over people
who are generally good,
but sometimes say
controversial things
or do controversial things.
(laughing)
'Cause I was asking him,
how's he best friends
with Jimmy Kimmel, right?
Who doesn't seem to
really like conservatives,
and Adam pretty much is.
Like, how does that work?
And he just sees everybody
in terms of, look,
that's not a bad person there
who's doing good things.
Even AOC, right? She's
not a bad person.
She's young, she's
a whippersnapper.
She got herself elected to
congress from being a bartender.
On some level, you've
got to respect that.
You don't have to agree with
a word she says politically.
And you don't have to like
her judgments of other people.
But should we be
focused on tearing down,
let's see the civilian
AOCs of the world?
No. Why do we get
so upset about them.
They might be a minor irritant.
Like Sunny Hostin, I
was just ripping on her
'cause she's got
hostility for everybody.
Do we really need to worry
about the Sunny Hostins? No.
Should fight the
political battles,
Just don't get so upset
personally, over these people.
When it's coming into your life
and it has the power
to like fire you
or make you lose your job
or endanger your children,
you gotta perk up and
you got to pay attention.
But you don't have to
get personally offended
by everything somebody
else stands for.
- You did it to me last time.
And you did it this time,
which is, you know how
to end an interview.
Because we could keep going here
and talk more about
politics or the election.
But I think that
was it. That was it.
I'm not gonna drag
out anything else.
That that was just perfect.
So we are gonna link to
the podcast down below.
- Thank you sir.
- Thanks for taking the time.
- Subscribe, you've
gotta subscribe.
- Oh subscribe. Very
important to subscribe.
And enjoy the weekend, Megyn.
Don't think about
politics the whole time
have fun with the
kids and the dog.
- That's the plan!
- And the husband.
And the husband.
Hopefully we'll do
this in real life soon,
- See you soon
Dave, lots of love.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.